el ritmo contagioso de los tambores
retumba por fin en la avenida marqués de
sapucaí la más amada por los cariocas
la primera escuela de samba que pisa el
sambódromo tras las restricciones
impuestas por el coronavirus ostenta un
nombre muy simbólico en el último minuto
[Música]
es una expresión de victoria de
esperanza porque el carnaval hace parte
de los cariocas
desfilar durante casi una hora en el
templo de la samba requiere toda una
logística para que los 1800 componentes
lleguen a tiempo a la concentración
la jornada de thiago comenzó a las 5 de
la mañana en un tren rumbo a su trabajo
14 hora después y sin un solo minuto de
descanso se apresura hacia el lugar más
anhelado en los últimos dos años el
sambódromo
hoy para nosotros regresa todo aquello
que nos encanta desde siempre nuestra
válvula de escape es el momento en que
soltamos toda nuestra energía es la
vuelta del carnaval en este cuerpo
lozano se acumulan más de 50 desfiles en
el sambódromo vividos con intensidad a
lo largo de dos décadas pero cada vez es
como si fuese la primera el corazón se
dispara aquí ya empiezo a sentir las
mariposas en el estómago no veo la hora
de ponerme este disfraz y pisar la
avenida poco a poco los miembros de la
escuela de samba llegan desde varios
puntos de la ciudad algunos incluso
desde más lejos de méxico y de argentina
un carnaval
son muy bienvenidos siempre siempre ya
falta menos para el desfile la
concentración es un fervor y la emoción
se palpa en el ambiente con estos
disfraces aparatosos una ayuda siempre
viene bien
estoy dando los últimos retoques para
que el traje quede perfecto
ajustes de última hora en los carros
alegóricos también son necesarios estaba
intentando resolver un problema con la
luz qué pasa si no se resuelve perdemos
puntos
[Música]
y en el último minuto asombrosamente
todo queda listo parece un milagro pero
es la magia del carnaval carioca caótico
y organizado anárquico y disciplinado
explosivo y sobre todo desafiante
[Música]